welcome back to me rock stars I'm Erik
Voss and Black Widow is officially
wrapped filming with some images
revealing some interesting ways this
film could tie in to the broader MCU
with surprise cameos and a possible post
credits scene spoiler warning because
they will be revealing behind the scenes
images for Black Widow that you might
not want to see and speculating where
this movie could go which you might not
want to hear but you're clicked and I
started open in my mouth and there's
train ain't stopping and thanks to
privacy icon for sponsoring this episode
if you go to privacy comm slash indie
rock stars you can get five dollars
today to use on any purchase online for
free stick around for more details on
that okay so as we wait for an official
black widow movie trailer hopefully
coming soon here's what we know about
the film it will be a solo story for
Natasha Romanov set in two time periods
a period between civil war and infinity
war when she was on the run and an
earlier time period before she joined
the Avengers joining Natasha Anna's
story will be Florence pew as Yelena
Bulova a blonde rival to Natasha in the
comics with a similar KGB assassin
background who attempts to take the
black widow title from her many have
also speculated that since Natasha died
in Avengers endgame this movie's role
could be to establish a new character in
the wings ready to carry the torch after
Natasha's death with like Florence Pugh
as the new Black Widow and face forward
beyond but all this is opened up the
mystery of who exactly the New Avengers
lineup could be going forward will this
team even be called Avengers and how
could Black Widow set up this next
lineup as it feeds into the immediate
next release in the Marvel calendar the
streaming series Falcon in the Winter
Soldier I will explore these questions
in this special update of inside Marvel
so along with Yelena Bulova also joining
this cast will be stranger things David
Harbor as Alexi Shostak of aka the red
Guardian from the Marvel Comics aka the
USSR's equivalent to Captain America his
body was not enhanced with Super Soldier
serum like caps was but he does have
advanced training and expertise with
weapons and week also saw set photo that
revealed a surprise cameo fattiest
Thunderbolt Ross appearing aged and with
a cane this has also fueled some
speculation that Black Widow either
through a post-credits scene or a secret
subplot that we don't know about yet
could be setting up a Marvel
Thunderbolts storyline with Thunderbolt
Ross as that team's Nick Fury type point
man so in the Marvel comics the
Thunderbolts appear as kind of a group
of supposed heroes who build the void
after The Avengers were declared dead
and the onslaught event but we find out
the Thunderbolts are actually disguised
villains organized by Baron Zemo from
his former supervillain group the
Masters of evil
they included beetle and fixer moonstone
screaming meanie but as the group called
the Thunderbolts they all take on new
heroic patriotic identities over time
the other members of the Thunderbolts
find Redemption and become known as
reformed superheroes they overturns emos
leadership their reason I bring this up
is because Daniel Bruhl as Zemo has been
set to return to the MCU and Falcon and
the Winter Soldier on Disney Plus why is
this important well the MCU Thunderbolts
could be a similar kind of team maybe
known as the Dark Avengers composed of
Deep Cover ex-soviet assets to go on
missions that Thunderbolt Ross did not
want or trust the Avengers to be a part
of it could include the likes of Yelena
Bulova and Alexi show sykov I'm gonna
explain how this team could go into
effect in the Black Widow plot but
before we continue thank you to privacy
comm for sponsoring this episode
privacy comm is a free service let's see
I buy things online using these burner
virtual cards set of your real credit
card info so that you can protect
yourself on the internet yeah it's a
digital burning card with limits that
you control it's great so you don't have
to worry about it you know shady vendors
using your card info to buy seven Winter
Soldier arms why do you need so many
hands you know what I regret asking that
but also privacy calm lets you avoid
having to just hand over the keys to all
your finances every time you sign up for
a subscription but you know those folks
are just waiting to sting you up before
you have a chance to cancel that
so for example I have set up an account
with privacy linked by bank account and
then created a card specifically for my
monthly Netflix subscription payments
for this virtual card I'm setting the
limit to just above my monthly
subscription rate so that if someone
tries to use this privacy card number
again or overcharge its privacy well
notify you they blocked it too because
the spending limit was already reached
see it's simple it's fast it's really
just one click it's so easy and again
it's free we're gonna make this deal
even better for you guys first time
customers who sign up with privacy calm
slash new rock stars will get five
dollars off their first purchase with
privacy calm just go to privacy calm
slash new rock stars
that's PRI the Acy dot-com / any wroc KS
da RS to get five dollars off your first
purchase now ok back to what a
Thunderbolts Dark Avengers team could be
up to in Black Widow perhaps after the
events of Civil War
Natasha Romanov is on the run after
switching teams and defying secretary
Ross's sokovia accords so to hunt down
etosha across the globe Rask deploys own
secret hit squad of assassins kind of
like his Kill Bill deadly Viper
assassination squad except he calls them
the Thunderbolts or the Dark Avengers or
like undercover Ross's then after the
events of Black Widow in the Marvel
Universe post in the game a present time
that is set as 2023 or 2024 time when
Ross would be significantly older maybe
need a cane this old man could activate
that team to fill the void in the world
after the Avengers are gone as well as
Nick Fury who appears to be in space
with the scrolls
now I've theorized that he could be
overseeing the MCU version of sword and
that could be the peak Space Station
command center anyway in this void on
earth Ross would want to promote his
backup Dark Avengers into prime time
maybe even using Zemo to force the
Winter Soldier to join their ranks using
that Hydra brainwashing code now in
tomarrow comics the Dark Avengers were
initially formed from former
Thunderbolts and later they were grouped
with John Walker aka u.s. agent who has
been confirmed to be played by white
Russell in the Falcon Winter Soldier
series essentially all the pieces are in
place over the MCS next two properties
to set up a Thunderbolts Dark Avengers
type storyline and in this post in the
game world in which the media has turned
on the surviving superheroes this sounds
like an era when the bad guys will reign
supreme with rumours that Sam Wilson is
going to be viewed as a threat by the US
government this could be the source of
that antagonism a post Nick Fury post
cap
starke earth in which of the government
figures finally have a chance to take
the reins of the planet security they've
seen an old guard of heroes who are
trying to continue the legacy of those
who knew how to avenge the right way why
do you want the New Avengers lineup to
be comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at
both it subscribe to new rockstars to
join me as i go deeper and deeper inside
marvel and if you would like to help in
this awkward semi-homeless transition
period that we're still stuck in and
finished construction our new home new
rock stars digital studios please
consider becoming a patron of n RDS
patrons will get access to special
rewards including an exclusive monthly
breakdown so if you're interested click
on the link in the description below for
details thank you for joining me and hey
nice try with the old man makeup and
cane secretary Ross we know you're the
undercover Ross you're not gonna hear
any [ __ ] talk from us and they have to
get that undercover Goss from somewhere
else
[Music]